Good imagery makes us form
a connection to the subject,
sympathizing with their joy,
pain, or delight.
Though only visual,
a good image might even make us
recall a familiar smell or sound.
Migrant Mother by Dorothea Lange
is the iconic representation of
the Great Depression
in the United States.
In it, we see a mother with a steely
gaze into the future unsure of the end
of her current crisis.
It put a face and a feeling to what
migrant workers were experiencing during
the Great Depression.
Afghan Girl by Steve McCurry appeared
on the cover of National Geographic in
June 1985.
It's one of these most recognizable
magazine covers ever, and
has become a symbol of the status
of refugees worldwide.
So, what do these two moving photographs
have to do with Android design?
A lot.
Though they come from different eras,
both tell an immersive and
compelling story and
can connect emotionally.
Neither feels like stop imagery or
clip-art.
While every photo or illustration you
use need not be Pulitzer Prize quality,
you should seek to select imagery
that is relevant to the user,
provides contextual information,
or delights them.